there needs to be ramifications for poor
decisions so how do they just think like
how did they distinguish to let AIG to
to allow them to stay but Layman and
bear Stearns like who's picking these
situations at the end of the day
this whole too big to fail concept
it's sort of
the antithesis of what capitalism is
right like if you screw up you make poor
decisions like if an individual does
this and they spend all their money
they'd max out credit card debt they
they go on vacation when they should be
just saving money and they lose their
job and they fail then it's kind of
expected but when companies do that why
should they receive these bailouts
[Music]
[Applause]